et on commence au burkina faso avec
l'ouverture d'un procès historique
aujourd'hui devant le tribunal militaire
de ouagadougou celui des personnes mises
en cause dans l'assassinât de l'ancien
président thomas sankara et de 12 de ses
compagnons le 15 octobre 1987 un procès
en l'absence du principal accusé l'ex
président burkinabè blaise compaoré il
est exilé en côte d'ivoire depuis 2014
et il est sous le coup d'un mandat
d'arrêt international à l'ex compagnon
de route de sankara est poursuivi pour
complicité d'assassinât assassinat et
atteinte à la sûreté de l'état les
explications de notre reporter à abidjan
lit la femme ouzou
ce procès sera non pas douter très
suivis ici en côte d'ivoire tout d'abord
parce que thomas sankara a acquis une
aura qui va bien au-delà des frontières
du burkina faso de celui qu'on a
surnommé le che guevara africain
représente une figure emblématique de la
lutte anti impérialiste et continue
d'être une source d'inspiration sur le
continent alors sous la présidence de
blaise compaore il était impossible de
faire la lumière sur cet assassinat et
ce malgré elle les pressions
internationales à ce n'est qu'à la
faveur du renversement de l'ex président
burkinabé en 2014 après 27 ans au
pouvoir que la machine judiciaire a pu
se mettre en route entre temps blaise
compaore s'est exilé en côte d'ivoire il
a obtenu la nationalité ivoirienne et il
ne peut pas être extradé car la côte
d'ivoire n'extrade pas ses
ressortissants
malgré l'absence du principal accusé les
avocats des familles des victimes se
veulent optimistes la justice fera son
travail il n'y aura pas d'obstacle à la
vérité judiciaire alors l'absence ans le
refus de blaise compaore d'assister à
son propre procès est perçue par
beaucoup d'observateurs ici comme
finalement un aveu de culpabilité mais
du côté des avocats de l'ex président
burkinabé on dénonce un procès politique
auquel blaise compaore refuse de se
soumettre